- Well, speaking of
wigs, you brought it up.
The book has this picture of you,
which is fantastic!
(Kelly laughs)
So what's going on here?
And how many drugs were you on?
(Kelly laughing)
- Well, that was taken, (laughs)
- I mean, it looks awesome
- That was taken after
we wrapped the series,
after our very last scene doing the show
which was outside of the Rosebud Motel.
And we finished, we popped some champagne
and I was feeling rather merry
(kelly laughing)
and one of Moira's wigs
was being kinda of passed around
one of the trailers at that point.
And we were all kind of, you know,
in there together telling stories
and congratulating each other
and crying and saying goodbye.
And somebody put the wig on me
and it felt so good.
- Then captured it.
I do feel like you should
have an English accent
and you should be stoned.
(both laugh)
I think it would be a really
great character for something.